[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui sandra
luc berd pour personne ne sort les
fusils un livre sur le procès de france
télécom l'année dernière en 2019
alistair pour la bibliothèque impossible
une bibliothèque pleine de livres
imaginaire de livres interdits des
livres les plus chers et même de livres
de léon zitrone vous allez voir et
nicolas lafforgue et sandra da silva du
groupe 10 qui sort un album et n'être
qu'au milieu des monstres et l'on
commence par notre époque qu'est ce qui
la caractérise
la réponse en images d'un du groupe 10
pour commencer qu'est ce que c'est cet
appareil c'est un auto tune elle ne te
tue ouais c'est un auto tune c'est un
appareil qui corrige la voix et donc qui
est aujourd'hui qu' il ya une grosse
polémique auto cela paraît certain
trouve ça absolument incroyable l'autre
tous absolument horrible est ce qu'on
trouvait intéressant là dessus c'est que
il va permettra aux jeunes qui écoutent
leur musique aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
utilisé dans le rap actuel bas de d'être
tranquille pour les côtés puisque les
plus jeunes ont pu écouter du tout leur
musique puisqu'il trouve le son horrible
et je trouve que ça a un rapport
intéressant par rapport avec
l'apparition de la guitare électrique à
l'époque non des skis bruit ben l'auto
tune scinde les auditeurs au même niveau
c'est vous chantez avec un auto tune
cher votre album est ce que sandra ça
m'énerve
non ça va je me suis adapté
mais c'est vrai que c'est intéressant
parce que bon on n'est plus tout jeune
mais on s'est confronté aussi aimons
tous les deux le rap à l'arrivée de ces
nouveaux styles de rap soit s'arrête et
on reste des vieux cons qui refusant
d'écouter la suite
soit on s'adapte et on comprend qu'elle
ait choisi père intéressante at ease eh
ben on écoutera ça tout à l'heure et
lyster votre image à vous celle ci comme
une image qu'on a beaucoup vu ces
derniers jours
et oui c'est d'être un homme qui joue au
golf au moment où
on annonce qu'il a sans doute perdu
l'élection
je trouverais que ça aurait été une
bonne façon pour lui juste après cette
partie flamboyante d'accepter les
résultats peut-être et qu'il aurait fini
sur un espèce de comme ça deux de pique
mais bon apparemment il refuse donc mais
voilà presque sympathique sur sur cette
photo et sur l'a6 avait fini comme ça ça
va je pense qu'on a été plutôt positif
pour lui mais bon il ne peut pas y voit
pas mais il n'a jamais reconnu aucune
défaite donald trump vois pas pourquoi
il commencera aujourd'hui jamais jamais
donc ces photos cette photo est ce ça
aurait été magistral comme sortie de
chignan là dessus ni rationnel
irrationnelle finira sans doute là
dessus
sandra lucbert vous ce sont deux photos
vous nous avez fait parvenir alors que
représente-t-elle exactement ce sont les
photos de ce qu'on a appelé le charnier
de paris 5 donc de l'université paris
descartes de médecine donc je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez de cette histoire
mais c'est le centre de don décor de
l'université de médecine de paris dont
on avait découvert qu'au bout de 25 ans
d'abandon en fait la totalité des corps
offert la science avait pourri donc on a
retrouvé des sacs entiers d'organes
putréfiés des rats qui mangeaient les
corps des mégots enfoncé dans les
viscères j'en passe et des meilleurs et
donc j'ai choisi cette image parce que
j'y vois le concentré de ce que la
rationalité néolibérale promet comme des
saints à l'humanité et comme on le voit
il ya des caches sur l'image parce que
c'est un destin qui n'est pas très
enviable et mieux vaut se le cacher et
pourquoi parce que la rationalité
néolibérale
elle considère les humains comme des
choses on le voit bien dans le cas du
carnet du charnier où non seulement ce
sont des corps humain qu on est terrifié
mais des corps humains morts or
normalement les corps humain mort ce
sont ceux à qui on réserve un traitement
spécial dans l'humanité c'est la
symbolisation qui caractérise les
humains et on voit ici que cette
symbolisation a été complètement annulé
elle a été annulée
donc parce que la rationalité
néolibérale
elle considère les choses en général
quelle qu'elle soit la nature et les
humains comme enfin comment dire ces
paroles en deux catégories les profits
et les coûts comptables et là
manifestement dans le cas du centre de
don de corps la rationalité managériale
ne pouvait pas envisager qu'il
s'agissait là d'un profit puisqu'il
n'était pas comptable et donc ils l'ont
rangé dans la colonne des coûts ce qui
fait qu'on en 25 ans ils ont laissé les
corps pourrir or ces corps mort là
n'était pas n'importe quel corps mort
non seulement ils auraient dû avoir
droit à une symbolisation minimale mais
qui plus est il s'agissait de corps de
gens qui de leur vivant avait choisi
d'offrir leurs corps à la médecine c'est
à dire à l'humanité autrement dit ces
corps là aurait dû avoir droit à encore
plus de respect en lieu et place de quoi
le néolibéralisme leur offre cette fin
absolument atroce à l'état de cadavre
putréfié je voulais y insister parce que
quand on essaye de réduire les coûts à
toute force c'est ce qui se passe dans
le cas des corps mauricie et dans
l'entreprise c'est pour ça que j'en
parle ici parce que mon livre porte sur
ça c'est ce qui se passe avec les
salariés quand il faut réduire les coûts
qu'est ce qu'on fait on comprime la
masse salariale comme on l'appelle c'est
à dire que ont réussi les humains
jusqu'à les dégagée par la porte ou par
la fenêtre comme disait didier lombard
le l'ancien pdg de france télécom est
donc pour dire une dernière chose là
dessus
il me semble que ce que cette image nous
montre ces que la rationalité
managériale appliquées à l'université ou
à la recherche c'est comme dans
l'entreprise ça donne une chosification
qu'est une déshumanisation absolue en
fait le geste par lequel certains
hominidés sont entrés dans l'humanité
véritable c'est précisément celui de la
symbolisation funéraire ça s'est fait en
fait en france dans le périgord noir
puisque je ne sais pas si vous le savez
mais le berceau de l'humanité en europe
c'est dans le périgord noir dans une
zone qu'on appelle la vallée de l'homme
parce que la grammaire la syntaxe
française est extrêmement sexiste donc
au lieu de dire la vallée du monde il a
avalé de l'homme mais en tout cas quand
l'homme de néandertal a institué les
rites funéraires et nous a fait entrer
dans l'humanité et ça me semble
saisissant parce qu'il se trouve que cet
été j'étais dans la vallée de l'homme et
j'ai vu que pour des raisons d'économies
budgétaires la communauté de communes
vallée de l'homme avait décidé de
remplacer la tournée des ordures par
l'installation de déchetterie où les
gens devaient
et eux mêmes leurs déchets jour après
jour et j'ai vu dans un village connu
pour les trouvailles préhistoriques ont
bien fait que cette déchetterie avait
été précisément installé juste à côté du
cimetière
or je trouve qu'il y alla raccourci
saisissant
parce que dans un monde néolibéral plus
personne ne voit le problème de mélanger
des déchets et des corps humains morts
et dans un monde néolibéral il me semble
que même dans cette vallée de l'homme on
assiste à un raccourci absolument
effrayant ou là où l'humanité est apparu
avec l'homo sapiens sapiens l'humanité
est en train de s'autodétruire avec
l'homo economicus qui confond les
humains et les déchets alors je voulais
commencer par ces images pas par goût du
macabre mais pour montrer à un point
maximal
quelle était la tendance générale de
l'ordre socio économico politique dans
lequel nous sommes
et cette tendance elle est simple c'est
un avertissement qui nous est donné là
où règnent l'efficacité managériale et
la rationalité économique sans plus
aucun appareil de deux contrecarre mans
et bien l'humanité est en danger point
elle est en danger sous sa forme corps
morts dans l'est dans le non respect qui
est désormais dévolue au corps mort mais
elle l'est aussi pour les corps vivant
comme ça a pu être le cas à france
télécom et comme c'est partout le cas
aujourd'hui dans le privé comme dans le
public
voilà eh bien on va parler tout de suite
de votre livre sandra lucbert commençons
[Musique]
sandra lucbert vous avez donc écrit deux
romans mobile et la toile et là vous
publiez personne ne sort les fusils aux
éditions du seuil
c'est donc sur le procès de france
télécom en 2019 ou scène dirigeant était
accusé de harcèlement moral l'échelle
d'une entreprise 19 salariés s'étaient
suicidés entre 2006 et 2010 ce procès
certains y ont vu le procès de nuremberg
du management est-ce que c'est aussi
votre avis alors en réalité cette
formulation l'union envers du management
je m'en suis servi dans mon texte parce
que elle revenait avec insistance d'un
peu partout à la fois aux audiences et
or des audiences donc sous des formes
plus ou moins vagues et allusive
mais la formule précise que vous évoquez
elle vient d'une émission live du figaro
qui était consacrée au procès et elle
avait été sélectionnée par le community
manager c'était un tweet
mais de la même manière j'ai lu une
comparaison entre le procès france
télécom le procès eichmann dans fakir
donc à l'autre bout du spectre politique
et au procès lui même
l'analogie entre les situations d'asie
et la situation managériale elle avait
été faite aussi bien par l'avocat de la
défense donc du pdg lombard m veille que
par brigitte pesquié qu'était la
procureure donc le côté de l'accusation
alors non pas que moi j'ai fait cette
analogie personnellement mais en
entendant revenir cette comparaison avec
tant d'insistance une comparaison aussi
chargé et à la fois aussi vagues
j'ai eu un réflexe qui est à la fois un
réflexe de littéraire est un réflexe
psychanalytique qui a été de me dire si
ça revient sans cesse ainsi c'est que ça
fait symptômes
c'est à dire c'est que cette comparaison
manifestement mal maîtrisée qui met tout
montrait en colère qui empêche les gens
de réfléchir mais qui insiste elle est
là pour dire quelque chose qui ne
parvient pas à se dire autrement
alors j'ai essayé d'y réfléchir parce
que en psychanalyse on sait bien que une
formation signifiante inadéquate qui
insiste si on ne sait pas de l'élaborer
elle va revenir sous forme de passage à
l'acte d'une manière ou d'une autre
donc en y réfléchissant je me suis rendu
compte qu'en réalité cette comparaison
était là pour dire les violences
structurelle du capitalisme sous la
seule forme qu'il était possible de
trouver et pourquoi on ne pouvait pas la
dire autrement on pouvait pas la dire
autrement parce que plus aucune
formation discursive plus aucune manière
de
si on était disponible pour qualifier ce
que le capitalisme nous fait subir et
j'ai donc grâce à cette réflexion autour
de cette formule qui revenait en fait
différencier les deux procès c'est à
dire que ce qui se passait au procès de
nuremberg ce qu'il y avait une
scénographie extrêmement insistante du
fait qu'on jugeait le monde l'asie
depuis un autre monde
le monde américains alliés qui insistait
sur la différence de valeur qui le
séparait du monde nazis considéraient
comme barbare etc
en revanche au procès faust et comme il
n'y avait pas d'extériorité depuis
laquelle on pouvait juger les managers
bien au contraire
moi ce qui m est apparu dans la salle
d'audience c'est qu'on jugeait une
certaine forme de capitalistes de
capitalisme pardon depuis cette forme de
capitalisme on devait incriminer les
méfaits capitaliste depuis la langue qui
justifiait toutes les méthodes
capitaliste donc en réalité les deux
procès était parfaitement différents
mais cependant savait vraiment un sens
que les gens utilisent sans cesse cette
comparaison
ça disait ça ça disait de manière
redoublé qui n'avait plus d'extériorité
à l'hégémonie néo libéral voilà est là
c'est vrai que boivent dans un premier
temps je me suis dit bon c'est un peu
gros quand même comparé le procès de
france télécom au procès de nuremberg
c'est un peu gros ne considérant pas en
ce qui me concerne le capitalisme comme
du nazisme et en même temps ou ferme bio
j'ai lu votre livre je me suis dit elle
véritablement quelque chose vous avez
raison il ya quelque chose notamment le
fait qu'ils avaient un plan pour se
débarrasser c'est le mot se débarrasser
de 22 mille salariés et 10000 mobilité
sur un effectif total de 120 mille
personnes travaillant à france télécom
bien un plan on veut l'exécuter ça
s'appelle à un crash programme et et ils
l'admettent
en fait ils en parlent entre eux
ils n'ont pas l'air de le cacher
simplement il emploie un langage pour
pour atténuer la brutalité mais au fond
ils sont tous d'accord et au procès tel
que vous le décrivez en tout cas ses
dirigeants continuent d'être fier d'eux
ils comprennent pas ce qu'on leur
reproche au fond ça a été un succès et
il voit pas pourquoi il en aurait eu à
rougir ils ont une totale indifférence l
égard des souffrances qu'ils ont pu
causer et même des morts qu'ils ont pu
provoquer oui absolument
alors je pense qu'il ya deux choses dans
votre question il ya l'aspect
déshumanisation il ya le fait que cette
déshumanisation soit banalisé pour ce
qui est de la déshumanisation c'est pour
ça que j'ai commencé par la photo des
charniers de paris 5 la déshumanisation
elle s'explique sur trois niveaux ici
mais elle s'explique sur un premier
niveau qui est celui qui disait tout à
l'heure la rationalité économique allait
chosifie catrice elle instrumentalise
tout ce qu'elle investit qu'il s'agisse
de la nature ou des humains peu importe
donc vous savez que dans le langage
économique on dit qu'il ya des intrants
du facteur capital ou du facteur travail
quand on met une machine au rugby ou un
numéro but c'est exactement la même
chose
première chose donc à partir du moment
où cette logique règne la chosification
et ne pose problème le problème pardon à
personne première chose deuxième chose
il me semble que dans le cas de france
télécom
nous nous trouvons au terme de quarante
ans de ressassement de ces soi-disant
nécessité qui sont celles du capitalisme
financiarisé et comme gramsci l'a fait
remarquer lorsqu un ordre et hégémonique
hégémonique ça veut dire lorsqu un ordre
de domination est devenue la direction
générale d'une société
cela veut dire qu un ensemble
d'appareils on naturalise et son
existence et l'ont transformée en cela
va de soi en c'est comme si en ordre
naturel des évidences et ça c'est tout à
fait ce qui explique l indifférence des
prévenus à ce qui pouvait se passer sous
leurs yeux
aussi bien il ya dix ans que à la salle
d'audience et j'irai même plus loin que
vous c'est à dire il n'était pas non
seulement indifférent ils étaient
scandalisés qu'on leur fasse des
reproches
didier lombard a reçu une légion
d'honneur pour ses bons et loyaux
services à france télécom et il n'a
cessé de répéter du début à la fin du
procès qu'il estimait que pour le
sauvetage qui l'avait mené tout cela
était d'une grande ingratitude
je le cite ces suicides 10 et il sait
terrible ils ont gâché la fête donc pour
eux en réalité on leur avait demandé
quelque chose l'ensemble du corps social
demander quelque chose et on montrait
une espèce de commandes hypocrisie
terrible à venir leur faire des
reproches
dix ans après alors qu'ils avaient fait
une opération formidable et ceci est le
fait de l'hégémonie telle que la définit
gramsci c'est à dire si tous vous porte
à suivre la la chosification tels que la
rationalité économique l'exigent
dans un monde capitaliste où il n'y a
plus aucune régulation adverse à celle
simplement de la valorisation financière
du capital et bien il est normal que
vous agissiez dans ce sens là c'est ça
la banalisation que produit la langue à
la suite des structures capitalistes
régnante et j'ajouterais du coup une
troisième chose c'est que par rapport à
cette rationalité économique minimale
dans le capitalisme financiarisé c'est à
dire celui dans lequel nous sommes
le régime de propriété est encore plus
chosifie catr que celui qui régnait
auparavant parce que le nôtre c'est
celui qu'on appelle la liquidité
financière et la liquidité financière
c'est la possibilité pour les
propriétaires de disposer de quelque
chose de s'en débarrasser quasiment
instantanément en fait instantanément à
la nanoseconde
donc on peut acheter et revendre en
permanence ça vient bien sûr des marchés
d'actifs mais ça s'est généralisée à
tous les objets du monde
c'est devenu le rapport la relation
d'objets principal que nous avons à
toutes choses et notamment que les
patrons euros à toute chose
donc quand les actionnaires exigent des
profits illimité et c'est là justement
on va le faire avec toute chose
disponible donc notamment des salariés
dont quand didier lombard 10 en 2006 on
va on va faire les départs par à porte
ou par la fenêtre
il ne le dit pas du tout de manière
provocatrice il le dit parce que c'est
la nécessité qu on a posé en principe
est que pour lui du coup nécessité fait
loi
donc il y à ici en effet typique de ce
qui se passe dans un andré et monique
des structures créé une situation et
ensuite celle ci est ratifié
machinalement à chaque fois que nous
prononçons les formules qui en font à
cela va de soi voilà je sais pas si ma
réponse oui oui tout à fait
on voit bien que vous le dites dans
votre livre également qu'au fond se
débarrasser de ses salariés supprimé des
emplois est devenu le coeur de leur
métier et c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup
plus facile au fond que de conquérir de
nouvelles parts de marché de faire des
innovations qui vous parle vont
permettre d'enrichir la société de créer
de la richesse tout simplement
ne sachant plus créer de la richesse on
a une partie de nos élites qui n'est
plus là que pour supprimer des emplois
au fond c'est comme ça qu'elle arrive à
justifier sa présence et ça m'a rappelé
le livre ii des manuels tod sur les
luttes de classe au 21e siècle
lui-même voyant les élites françaises en
train de 7 10 et leur propre peuple pour
se venger au fond d'être devenus des
élites de second rang vous le voyez
aussi comme ça ou pour vous c'est
simplement le la machinerie du
capitalisme qui arrive à des choses
pareilles en réalité je pense pas du
tout qu'il le voit comme ça de ce que
enfin moi ce que j'ai essayé de montrer
dans le texte c'est pour ça que j'ai
donné un nom à cette langue qui
accompagne et banalisent toutes ces
opérations du capitalisme financiarisé
je les appelais la lcn la langue du
capitalisme néolibéral
à la suite de victor klemperer ce qui
rejoint en fait que vous me posiez comme
question à l'instant parce que victor
klemperer c'est un philologue linguiste
qui pendant le troisième reich a
travaillé a qualifié la langue du
troisième reich qu'il appelait la lingua
tertii imperii la lt y la langue du
troisième reich en latin parce que il
constatait ge dit il c est une citation
que les victimes et les bourreaux
parlaient la même langue
ce qui était exactement ce que j'ai vu
dans les salles d'audience mais ce qui
est aussi le cas dans toute la société
française et moi je voulais faire comme
lui je voulais qualifier ça parce que
une langue qui pose en son principe un
certain nombre d'objectifs rang en fait
toutes les opérations nécessaires pour
l'atteindre légitime quelle qu'elle soit
quel que soit le niveau de barbarie donc
moi je pense plutôt que c'est comme ça
que ça se passe dans leur tête je pense
pas qu'il s'agisse sadisme je pense
qu'il s'agit de
de mettre en place toutes les opérations
rendues nécessaires et banale et banal
par l'opération de réitération infinie
des catégories même catégorie et j'irai
un peu plus loin parce qu'à l'intérieur
du texte moi j'ai essayé de faire
entendre
c'est marrant parce que c'est une des
questions que je me suis posée au début
et qui a motivé l'écriture du livre
c'est que le dans un régime d'évidence
quand il ya une langue hégémonique comme
la lcn la langue du capitalisme
néolibéral les dominés et les dominants
la parlent tous les deux ce qui fait que
les dominés par une langue qui leur
donne comme programme d'être chosifié
puis liquéfié on s'explique du coup
beaucoup mieux pourquoi les salariés se
suicident à la fin parce qu'ils n'ont
pas d'autres programmes intérieurs si
vous voulez c'est l'exact équivalent de
ce que disait frantz fanon à propos des
colonisés qui parlait la langue des
colonisateurs
de ce fait les colonisés n'avait pour
destin que celui d'être asservi puis
détruit donc fanon demande dans les
damnés de la terre enfin exige que l'on
change enfin de langue quand on est un
colonisé pour sortir de l'état de
colonisation et c'est la même chose que
pour les colons les colonisateurs
aujourd'hui avec les patrons et les
managers ils parlent une langue qui leur
raconte la grande épopée de leurs deux
lors comment dire de leur trajectoire
professionnelle et de ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire de merveilleux pour
l'humanité didier lombard c'est pour ça
que j'ai voulu le faire écouter à la fin
il est habité par le mythe de
l'innovation
il n'a pas du tout l'impression d'être
un patron de second rang au contraire il
est dans une lutte permanente pour selon
lui à mener l'humanité à davantage de
techniques à davantage de réalisations
face à l'exacte toutes ces réalisations
après qu'ils aient des ajustements
humain à faire pour ça il n'en a que
faire
c'est ce qui était évident au moment du
procès et c'est tout à fait vrai pour
les autres managers je les fais entendre
dans des poèmes intérieur du texte parce
que moi il s'agissait aussi de faire
comprendre ce que ces gens avaient dans
leur tête
parce que l'étonnement des salariés dix
ans après les faits dans la salle
d'audience quand ils constataient qu'il
n'y avait toujours aucun remords et
qu'il ne voyait toujours pas le problème
c'est une des choses qui m'a jetée dans
une rage folle avec l'indifférence des
patrons justement et je me suis dit il
faut écrire un livre pour qu on entre
enfin dans la tête de ces gens pour
qu'on comprenne
de quel régime d'évidence il est
question pour que nous nous soyons
rendus au suicide et que eux ils se
sentent toujours impeccable des années
après quand on fait défiler tous les
jours devant leurs yeux pendant 2
moi des gens qui se sont suicidés avec
les fils du téléphone jeté sur les rails
poignardé en réunion immolé par le feu
on parle de choses vraiment atroce le
procès france télécom s'était pas une
sinécure
donc du coup voilà moi c'est beaucoup
plus comme ça je vois les choses
oui se racontent une histoire de de
dynamisme et novateur de compétitivité
fort mal et c est la réalité il ne la
distingue pas du tout avec les mêmes
vieux cno voilà mais alors là où votre
livre ne va pas là où et en tout cas pas
pour moi en tant que lecteur je n'arrive
pas à voir ni le néo libéralisme ni le
capitalisme comme les seuls responsables
d'une telle déviation au fond ce votre
livre m'a fait penser au zéro et
l'infini kita livre de arthur koestler
qu'il a écrit sur les procès de moscou
et qu'est ce qu'on voit dans ce livre
dans l'épreuve dans le terreau et
l'infini on voit des communistes
victimes exactement de la même chose
c'est-à-dire de la même chose ification
de la même réfik à sion et qui vont
alors eux aussi alors non pas se
suicider mais accepter d'être condamnés
à mort pour des motifs absolument
délirant espionnage au profit des
etats-unis alors s'agit de vieux
révolutionnaire couturé de cicatrices
soudain il va accepter de s'accuser des
pires crimes tout ça pour que le parti
ait raison pour que le parti continue
pour que la révolution continue
ils vont se sacrifie nez sauf on se
suicide et moralement symboliquement
et c'est pour ça que je me dis mais ça
n'est pas le capitalisme qui fait ça
c'est simplement à un moment tout
système peut produire la même chose y
compris les suicides de france télécom
oui alors ça c'est l'effet des
idéologies je vous rejoins absolument
d'ailleurs moi à la fin je compare avec
la fin de l'homme rouge les techniques
étaient utilisées dans les soi disant
entretien d'évaluation qui permettait de
dégager en fait les salariés
je compare avec l'homme rouge parce que
en effet c'était les mêmes méthodes que
pendant la grande période soviétique
mais je voudrais dire deux choses à ce
propos la chosification la réification
et la déshumanisation en effet elles
sont transversales à différents systèmes
j'ai comparé avec la colonisation les
gens comparent avec les nazis vous
comparez avec les le régime soviétique
il me semble en effet que à chaque fois
on est dans des dérives qui amène à
cette chosification mais ce qui
m'intéressait moi c'est de cerner la
spécificité du néolibéralisme dans ce
cas d'abord parce que nous sommes encore
dans un moment où tout le monde partage
ses convictions sans le savoir en
répétant la langue qu'ils aient réitère
tandis que bon pas forcément pour tout
le monde visiblement pour la
colonisation mais en tout cas pour les
nazis et pour le régime soviétique
on a bien compris que ça avait été une
dérive ce qui n'est pas le cas pour le
néolibéralisme aujourd'hui donc moi je
voulais le faire apercevoir première
chose
et deuxième chose je pense que à chaque
fois il y à là enfin je pense que chez
les humains la tentation de réifier les
autres humains au service de sa propre
persévérance est très forte et je pense
que quand des régimes offrent à certains
individus la possibilité de fonctionner
ainsi
il la saisisse et qu'ensuite c'est le
propre d'un ordre social que de faire
perdurer un ordre de domination le
faisant passer pour la direction
générale or dans le néolibéralisme dans
le capitalisme en général et dans le
néolibéralisme en particulier il y à
cette promesse de l'autonomie et du
comment dire de la relation d'objets
infiniment équitable qui est sans cesse
proposer et qui est particulièrement
proposé dans le régime financier dans
lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui du fait
ce régime de propriété que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure de la liquidité la
liquidité si on veut résumer un peu
brutalement c'est prendre et jetés en
permanence et en fait ce régime de
propriété il est généralisée partout pas
simplement à la bourse dans toutes les
relations d'objets y compris pour nous
comme consommateur sur les réseaux
sociaux sur les plates formes de
livraison sur les sites de rencontre et
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est que
nous sommes saisis à tous points de vue
par un régime de pulse youn alité et par
une proposition relationnel qui en fait
nous nous en sert dans un ordre de
domination qui lui est complètement
réifiant et déshumanisant et qui fait
que comme le disait m teissonnière
avocat des parties civiles
à la fin on a des entreprises comme
hubert qui est le sommet de la liquidité
financière qui nous considèrent nous
comme ceux qui coule quand on ouvre un
robinet et ceux qui s'arrête de couler
quand on ferme le robinet donc c'est une
forme particulière de déshumanisation je
suis bien d'accord que le capitalisme
n'a pas l'apanage pas du tout simplement
ils la portent très loin or personne ne
la perçoit et il serait temps
d'apercevoir qu'il ya des causes
structurelles et des individus qui
installe ses causes structurelles et qui
les font opérer qui explique la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes et
le fait de se sentir est repris utilisé
est jeté ça pourrait être aussi si l'on
voulait voir en voir le côté sombre la
façon de résumer même nos relations
amoureuses nos relations sexuelles
notamment quand on est jeune et qu'on
veut pas cumuler les conquêtes
on sait bien que on va se faire on va
être utilisé ou on va utiliser et on va
être jeté
on sait aussi qu'il y en a qui se
suicident pour des raisons amoureuse la
question qu'on se pose à la fin de votre
livre c'est au fond quelle peine mérite
t-il on a toujours tendance et de serait
ce que parce que le livre parle de
sortir les fusils
on se dit après tout est-ce qu'on doit
est ce que est ce qu'on voit condamner
la personne pour laquelle un autre s'est
suicidé par amour par exemple on
n'imagine pas alors pourquoi condamner
quelqu'un à cause de qui l'on s'est
suicidé par par désespoir
c'est une vraie question oui je pense
qu'il ya une situation très différente
là parce que dans le cas des effets
structurels des violences structurelle
du capitalisme
il y a comme je le disais tout à l'heure
les effets d'un rapport de domination
d'un rapport de domination qui est
devenu absolument féroce parce que dans
le cas de la valorisation financière du
capital il n'y a plus
force de rappel sociales ou politiques
qui tiennent par opposition avec ce qui
se passait dans le régime fordiste donc
on a ici un rapport où le capital est
tout puissant où toutes les
autorisations lui sont données et où les
travailleurs au contraire sont livrés en
pâture à son bon vouloir et donc de ce
fait la situation n'a absolument rien à
voir avec une relation amoureuse ou de
manière interpersonnelles de personnes
s'engagent laon il ne s'agit pas d'un
terreau personnel c'était d'ailleurs une
des difficultés rencontrent elles la
sphère du droit justice pour juger les
effets structurels du capitalisme ce
sont des effets dont les causes sont
différées dont les effets oui c'est ça
dont les causes sont différées et
difficilement rattachables aux effets
délétères
parce que en général des innovations
techniques ou sociaux institutionnels
ont lieu à un moment donné qu'ils sont
en général enveloppé dans la technicité
donc on ne les comprend pas bien et des
dizaines d'années après leurs effets
délétères se font connaître
j'en prends juste pour rapid exemple
dans le domaine socio institutionnels
l'installation par exemple des
structures financières ou du libre
échange ou de là comment dire de la
libre concurrence européenne mais dans
le domaine des innovations techniques
la titrisation le nucléaire l'amiante
médiator c'est dix ans après qu'on se
rend compte que les gens souffrent de
cette situation et moi ce qui
m'intéressait c'est le pourquoi du titre
c'est que au moment où ces innovations
lieu personne ne comprend vingt ans donc
c'est pour ça que je dis personne ne
sort les fusils c'est à propos de la
réforme de 1985 de pierre bérégovoy par
laquelle ils installent la
déréglementation financière mais en
réalité on se rend compte dix ans après
que les effets sont tellurique sur les
sociétés mais il est trop tard et la
justice quand elle s'empare de la
situation elle ne peut plus à cause de
la prescription attaquer les bons
coupable elle ne peut plus attaquer les
hommes politiques qui ont installé tout
ça fillon jospin chirac balladur
bérégovoy elle ne peut plus non plus
attaquées michel bon qui est le
responsable de l'endettement de france
télécom ni encore thierry breton qui est
le premier opérateur des plans
managériaux il ne reste plus que didier
lombard et son équipe raison pour
laquelle pendant le procès c'est ce
petit groupe là se sentait injustement
accusés parce que tous leurs amis s'en
était tirée indemne et les tandis que
eux ils se trouvaient les derniers
accusés donc moi c'était une des choses
qui m'intéressait c'était de dire
qu' il fallait identifier les vraies
causes de notre souffrance et identifié
l'ordre dans lequel nous étions comme
contingent puisque l'ordre financier a
commencé un moment donné dans les années
80 en france 83 84 85
et que cela implique que s'il a eu en
début il peut avoir une fin et qu'il
nous est loisible de considérer que si
cet ordre nous détruit nous devons y
mettre fin
et en cela ça n'a rien à voir avec une
relation amoureuse il s'agit vraiment
d'un rapport de domination et de ce
qu'ont choisi de faire quand on
identifie le fait qu'on est parmi les
dominer ou les subalternes comme dirait
gramsci voilà personne ne sort les
fusils c'est le titre du livre de sandra
lucbert qui vient de sortir au seuil
on fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
et nous voilà à présent avec alistair le
directeur de l'excellente revue schnock
et cela depuis 2011
aujourd'hui vous sortez la bibliothèque
impossible aux éditions la tengo
alors de quoi s'agit-il exactement
pourquoi cette bibliothèque est elle
impossible
et pourquoi est-ce que ça la rend
d'autant plus à la fois drôle et
fascinante tout simplement enfin je le
les livres sont quand même là la
meilleure sur les meilleurs outils pour
décrire un peu de l'âme humaine et de la
médiocrité à l'excellence de la beauté
et la laideur j'ai pensé que rapporter
tout ça dans un ouvrage dans une
anthologie était une bonne façon parler
de tous ces livres imaginaire oublier
interdit pas tous ses livres un peu
quand même un canard canard boiteux ou
voilà donc je sais c'est un jeu aussi
c'est un jeu en effet puisque vous avez
créé au fond la bibliothèque impossible
c'est la bibliothèque à laquelle
personne n'avait pensé c'est là qu'elle
bibliothèque absolument impossible à
réaliser
et pourtant il est là il est dans ce
livre de manière donc virtuel a commencé
donc dans cette bibliothèque vous rend
chez d'abord des livres imaginaire alors
les livres y imaginaire c'est que c'est
vrai qu'on en a lu dans plein de livres
l'auteur nous fait par exemple il ya il
ya ce livre de sherlock holmes on sait
charles comme ça jamais écrit deux
livres c'est le docteur watson qui écrit
des livres et pourtant si il en a écrit
et là il y en a un par exemple mais ce
livre là est un livre imaginaire il
n'existe pas et non il n'existe pas et
c'est le cédant le signe des 4 2 je
crois c'est bien que sherlock holmes
évoque ce livre sur les sur la
discrimination entre les différents tab
à 2 2
les différents tableaux et non mais oui
là c'est vraiment un exercice alors de
khâgneux de lui livre imaginaire dans la
littérature c'est c'est un grand un
grand fantasme d'étudiants en lettres
mais la sq était marrant c'est que j'ai
demandé à un graphiste qui s'est occupé
du livre monsieur choubi de réaliser des
couvertures originales de ces livres qui
n'existe pas en fait que dans le cerveau
là en l'occurrence de conan doyle et
c'est très réussi celui là on a vraiment
la pression tout à coup qu'il existe
yann vous devez vous y êtes pas risqué
c'est le très célèbre necronomicon qui
est né dans l'imagination de hp de ward
phillips lovecraft grands auteurs de
science-fiction mêmes d'horreur et se
livre le necronomicon écrit par l'arac
fou abdullah dredd nombre de gens sont
allés le demander dans des dans des
bibliothèques 1 et celui là vous ne lui
avait pas donné de couverture il est
trop grand il est trop pire et elle il
est trop sublime peut-être il est
peut-être trop en plus
enfin quand j'imagine le necronomicon et
j'imagine un grimoire un peu un peu
poussiéreux
j'ai trouvé que graphiquement c'était
peut-être dans intéressant mais bon on
aurait vu on aurait dû peut-être en
effet le faire alors vous avez en
revanche il va signer la lettre la
lettre et le néon le livre de jean sol
partre qui est dans le dans l'écumé des
jours de boris vian on le voit là jean
sol partre évidemment c'était le
personnage
en fait c'est jean paul sartre tourner
un peu en amitié et en dérision et ce
livre là c'est vrai qu'on en a beaucoup
parlé à l'époque ben oui mais c'est dans
l'écumé des jours et s'est attaqué à un
petit taquet que mais boris vian à la en
l'occurrence c'est vrai que la
réalisation est pas mal on dirait
vraiment un livre des années à des
années 40-50 quoi
parfait il et c'est exactement ça alors
il ya aussi les livres interdits
évidemment dans une bibliothèque
impossible comme la vôtre il faut des
livres interdits et alors vous êtes allé
en retrouver des livres qui ont vraiment
été interdits comme par exemple le
manuel du guérillero on le voit il est
tout petit en bas là mais manuel du
guérillero existe vraiment et il est
vraiment interdire ce livre il est il a
été il a été interdit il est plus du
tout mais il a été très très très
menaçants à la fin des années 60 pour
pour tout là pour tous les cas étaient
inquiétants pour les les autorités et
qui a été très inspirant pour pour la
gauche radicale de l'époque et y en a eu
beaucoup à ya le ca darkest cookbook si
c'est pareil à un livre qui a été
interdit de la même manière on va voir
aussi le petit livre rouge des écoliers
et des lycéens
on avait beaucoup peur des mouvements de
jeunes à l'époque 1 et est notamment
qu'il puisse armer et qu'ils puissent se
révolter de façon encore plus dur
oui en effet oui évidemment mais ce qui
est intéressant par rapport à
aujourd'hui c'est que ces menaces et de
de révolte ou de sédition été porté par
ces livres là que croyait bon interdire
les mystères l'intérieur enfin à
l'époque les autorités compétentes dans
ce genre de choses donc alors
qu'aujourd'hui quand on les vit
honnêtement que ce soit le manuel du
guérillero ce petit livre rouge
scandinave de ceux de deux professeurs
de gauche chansons sont assez sont assez
enfin il n'y a pas grand chose à part et
c'est toujours comme ça fait attention
quand on interdit un livre en fait c'est
toujours dérisoire à la fois c'est de
lui faire une une publicité considérable
et et c'est toujours vingt et un peu
stupide
de livres interdits liés à françois
mitterrand il ya l'honneur perdu de
françois mitterrand un livre de jean
edern hallier alors lui c'est pas
tellement qu'il est interdit c'est que
c'est un pamphlet on va on le voit là
bas la couverture telle qu'elle est
telle qu'il l'aura quand il sortira
enfin mais c'est assez un pamphlet qui
circule est écrit par jean edern hallier
contre françois mitterrand où il parle
de la fille cachée de françois
mitterrand
et c'est parce qu'il ya ce pamphlet que
des centaines de gens à paris vont être
écoutés il y aura des écoutes
téléphoniques insensé tout ça va durer
sur des années et puis finalement le
livre sortira il n'y aura absolument
aucun effet oui en fait ça a été une
espèce de douala celle de 2,2 de monstre
du loch ness
l'éditorial français des années 80 qui
en effet quand encore là où on voit la
couv qui est sorti je crois un mois
après la mort de mitterrand c'est pour
dire le le courage de jean yves hermann
mais en effet pendant dix ans il y avait
alors eh bien allez parler du passé
vichyste de mitterrand de la francisque
et tout ça mais surtout il parlait en
effet de mazarine qui étaient là en
effet c'était la nuit une arme nucléaire
donc presque vraiment mitterrand a oui
c'est sûr ça a été un problème mais
quand on voit le résultat final en effet
c'était beaucoup de bruit pour pas grand
chose
donc il ya un vent violent
il ya il ya aussi les meilleures
histoires drôles de carlos
alors là c'est plus étonnant que dès que
je ne connaissais pas ce livre est
mais que tel que vous le décrivez j'ai
compris pourquoi on l'avait interdite
l'esl histoires drôles de carlos qu'est
ce que c'est les histoires drôles de
carlos ne nous les raconter pas ça te
laruns sous le coup de la loi
mais expliquez nous pour grands les
interdite je suis même pas sûr que ça
tombe encore sous le coup de la loi
annoncé deux il ya donc carlos en 97-98
sort son recueil de meilleures histoires
drôles et à l'intérieur de ce recueil se
trouvent deux deux blagues entre
pédophilie inceste et enfin c'est un
filet ils cochent toutes les cases de la
blague qu'il faut pas faire et c'est un
des derniers livres est interdit aux à
la vente en france donc c'était il ya
quand même 20 ans c'est d'autant plus
intéressant que carlos est le fils de
françoise dolto grande pédiatre reconnu
donc voilà donc tout ça fait un objet
particulier qui sera rééditée sans les
bambins ces deux mauvaises blagues que
j'invite à lire dans mon livre quand
même parce qu'elles sont quand même
assez croustillante et alors il y en a
un autre c'est celui de léon degrelle
tintin mon copain alors l'est un livre
beaucoup plus sulfureux puisque léon
degrelle été reporter au petit vingtième
le journal dans lequel hergé a publié
ses premiers tintin en belgique léon
degrelle est devenu féscistes on a même
dit que hitler le considérait comme son
dauphin de léon degrelle a survécu la
seconde guerre mondiale et il a écrit ce
livre tu attends mon copain pour dire
qu'en fait tu as tes lui c'était lui le
reporter s'était inspiré hergé et je
connais c'est celui de réputation mais
je ne savais pas qu'il avait interdit la
vraiment est interdite se livre alors il
a été interdit par là pour pas pour des
raisons
étatique enfin deux capables papa par
une commission censure il a été interdit
par la société moulinsart sa qui
s'occupe désormais des intérêts de
tintin de tout ça est sans doute à juste
raison parce qu'en effet ça donne pas
une image très bonne d'hergé mais
maintenant bon il ya une quantité de
biographies et par ailleurs je parle
dans dans le livre d'autres d'autres
livres concernant quintin qui sont
problématiques comme tintin au congo
enfin on sait car j'ai n'était pas non
plus le plus grand social démocrate des
années des années 30 quoi donc
[Musique]
donc tout ça semble presque cohérent
mais en effet ce livre est interdit
parce que de grêle en effet un
personnage
alors il ya aussi un côté chez chez les
ch et c'est lui qui est qu un peu
mythomane ça il se disait très z de l'os
qui tous a donc cessé de grêle va alors
dans votre bibliothèque tu as possible à
lyster il ya également les livres
celluloïd
c'est vrai que dans un certain nombre de
films tout à coup on voit des livres
entre les mains des acteurs et ses
livres n'existe pas on en voit deux
spécimens ici même
ça doit être difficile de les retrouver
où vous aviez déjà collectionné chaque
fois vous voyez un film vous preniez une
petite photo du livre que l'acteur avait
entre les mains c'est passé un peu le
même principe que les livres imaginaire
en littérature de comme on a vu tout à
l'heure de charles comme ça c'est que
c'est des jeux en fait en effet mais bon
j'ai commencé avec le magnifique d'un
avec belmondo
il joue
le rôle de délivrer sinclar et
d'écrivains se dorer ça s est le truc
génial je trouvais c'est qu'il y avait
les couvertures en même temps envoyé
physiquement les livres apparaître sur
l'écran donc et puis après voilà il ya
l'homme qui aimait les femmes aussi de
truffaut ou le tout le scénario est
construit autour du fait que des nerfs
doit écrire ce ce livre donc voilà après
on prend des notes et puis on commence à
s'intéresser un peu à des chinois ou des
écrivains sont en train d'écrire des
ouvrages qui n'existe pas et ça devient
marrant il ya également les livres jeux
de mots qui pourraient peupler cette
bibliothèque impossible dans les livres
jumeaux les voilà on en a vu plein c'est
pas toujours de très bon goût c'est pas
très haut de gamme mais c'est des livres
dont les titres avec pur jeu de mot et
on espère que ça va suffire le rendant
c'est la fausse bonne idée par
excellence à son rang général le jeu de
mots est une fausse bonne idée mais là
en effet ça l'aventurière de l'archer
perdu par exemple de catherine lara ou
ce qu'on voit là c'est lewis et le feu
au culte des rings aise mais ça vaut le
coup de cet art déco c'est vraiment du
travail à l'aventurière de l'arche est
perdu catherine lara il fallait le faire
quoi ouais façon il ya toujours chez
quelqu'un qui fait un jeune homo il ya
toujours une espèce de de sympathie en
même temps un un truc pathétique quoi et
surtout pour en faire après un titre
douvres âge qui accroche ça accroche
comme dans la presse un jeu de mot ça
accroche mais je trouve quand qu'on ai
dit si l'on s'est un peu plus dangereux
parce que souvent derrière un grand
chose alors il ya aussi dans un taudis
dans notre bibliothèque cas possibles il
ya aussi les livres les plus chers par
exemple la bible
gutenberg dont il n'existe que 31
exemplaires ou les oeuvres de
shakespeare telles qu'elles ont été
imprimés autant de shakespeare ça il en
reste 288 exemplaires et aussi bien
cette bible de gutenberg que vous n'avez
pas illustré que le livre de shakespeare
qui est ici tel qu'il est sorti à
l'époque ça vaut 9 millions de dollars
chacun donc c'est vous êtes habitué à
voir ce que c'était que des livres
vraiment cher et puis parce qu'il faut
avancer il ya aussi les collections
improbable et là alors je dois dire que
j'ai j'ai vraiment ri au milieu des
années 90 on assortit cette colline à la
collection son premier cycle aux presses
universitaires de france
alors j'en ai aucune aucun souvenir il
faut croire que ça n'a pas eu tellement
de succès mais céder quoi l'idée de
cette collection à lyster il ya deux
choses fabuleuses déjà c'est que à
l'époque dans lé presses universitaires
de france on sont connus à l'époque pour
les que sais-je les que sèche qui sont
d'un point de vue de couverture
complètement neutre protestant à la et
on sait pas pourquoi
pendant trois quatre ans ça durait très
peu de temps cette histoire moi j'étais
à la fin qu'à l'époque donc je les
connais bien ses livres et ils ont
décidé d'incarner donc une vision
beaucoup plus catholique le leurs livres
par la figure des gens qui quittent les
écrivait dans des postures assez
incroyable et c'était de vivre assez
rare parce que ça coûte des livres qui
coûte cher à l'époque et qui coûte
encore plus cher aujourd'hui parce
qu'ils ont été éditées à très peu
d'exemplaires vous imaginez bien que
genre forme et donc voilà et c'est
devenu en effet déjà à l'époque c'était
une source de
de blague et tabler sur le physique des
auteurs alors qu'à priori c'était des
gens des intellectuels très sérieux pas
particulièrement bonne en fait c'est que
c'était des profs qu'on avait face à
nous c'était vraiment la figure des
profs d'hervé ya que des mecs à la rixe
est vraiment la la la la la la fine
fleur de de l'université française des
années 90 et on était censés aller
acheter après délivra qui coûtait à
l'époque 200 balles avec la tronche de
ces mecs sur la couverture c'était trop
demander évidemment aux étudiants que
nous étions alors pour finir c'est une
petite petite vengeance est une petite
vengeance personnelle et pour finir vous
avez
fait une section de cette bibliothèque
est possible qu'ils contiendraient tous
les livres de léon zitrone alors je dis
pour les plus jeunes
léon zitrone c'est un thé la plus grande
vedette de télévision française et il
écrivait régulièrement des livres
évidemment il était l'objet d'un culte
de la personnalité absolument terrible
lui-même je pense il y avait succombé
les couvertures de ses livres et il
écrivait surtout sur le tiercé sur les
chevaux sur l'urss parce qu'il était
d'origine russe sur les histoires
d'amour sur sur correspondance et à
chaque fois les livres étaient sublimes
on peut le dire c'est ce qui les rend
attirants pour une bio connaît votre nom
mais il ya là il ya une espèce de ces
espaces une marque des trente glorieuses
cette figure qui a mené tous les ans
sortait un livre que ça soit sur les
chevaux sur la crise cardiaque sur sur
sa femme sur le journalisme sur l'urss
sur les états unis alors que baa
parallèlement ils présentèrent elle
intervilles le journal télévisé terreau
enfin voilà quelqu'un qui n'arrêtait pas
on peut se demander d'ailleurs même si
c'est lui qui évidemment rédiger tous
ces chefs-d'oeuvre d'oakley la
bibliothèque impossible c'est le livre
de dahl easter qui est sorti aux
éditions la tengo
[Musique]
nous voici à présent avec le groupe 10
nicolas lafforgue et sandra da silva
dont l'album et n'être qu'au milieu des
monstres est sorti sur les plates formes
pour la voir physiquement il faudra
attendre le mois de janvier
je propose de regarder tout de suite un
extrait du clip de monstres justement
[Musique]
crochet
et cette tour qui appelle l'équipe dur
labeur mois qu'ils demandent
quand j'aurai
de combat
qui aurait bail
earl est plus ancienne
blaquart
soit
et allah
et dire qu'on après un trottoir trop
souvent pour se sentir vivant
trie pas les yeux ce
ceux touchant la main
asom
elle a
ancien
[Musique]
la nuit
à tort
personne
si van
souvent pour
souvent
ce sens dur
vous présentez comme un duo de rap
synthétique alors rappelez nous ce que
c'est que le rap synthétique alors de
trappes synthétique quoi je crois que
c'était une heure j'ai lu trappe santé
dit que j'ai reçu c'est une faute
jégo extreme 2 une coquille
non c'est du trap synthétique alors
c'est encore un sérieux que je croyais
mouvement trappe c'est une branche du
rap qui est bien apte l'on taille dans
quelques années qui est arrivée en
france par la suite et qui aujourd'hui
finalement et englobe tous les succès
rap actuel qu'on peut connaître et qui
sont aujourd'hui a mis en avant sont
issus de ce boom en train et donc rap
synthétique c'est parce qu'on a
enregistré toi et synthétiseurs a rien
sur pro tools et c'est tout avec nos
synthétiseur nos boîtes à rythmes
analogique etc et on a essayé de se
démarquer aussi par ça sandra da silva
oui bah oui ça fait partie de nos
influences cette nouvelle ces nouvelles
formes doha en fête et notamment au
niveau france un peu si ressort cpn elle
qui a été un grands marqueurs je pense
dans l'histoire du rap là en france de
cette nouvelle forme de rap qui marché
et qui viennent produits proposés des
sons qui sont intéressants et qui a été
une de nos influences on a toujours
l'impression en tout cas ceux qui ne
connaissent pas bien le rapport toujours
l'impression que l'europe n'a jamais
bougé qu'il n'a jamais changé de forme
on sait que le rock l'europe quand en 40
ans a beaucoup changé et pour passer
davis presley aux beatles puis ou heavy
métal puis au rock progressif et ensuite
pour devenir la variété internationale
il a pris comme ça plusieurs formes on a
l'impression que l'europe reste le même
ce n'est pas vrai non l'europe si on
prend par exemple en pnl vous dégoûte
pas encore plus encore plus récent qu'on
peut entendre qu'ils marchent en radio
avec 90 comme assassin ryan on voit que
ça m'a absolument rien à voir en terme
une sombre de thèmes abordés au niveau
du texte et par une évolution qui est
très marquée et là je parle que du rap
français dans
américain le concept aussi mais alors
vous votre rap à vous alors est ce que
c'est parce qu'il sait du trap et qu'il
est synthétique
il ya une production minimale moche pour
mot ce serait durable minimaliste
il ya dans le rapide tendance à
multiplier les couches aussi bien de son
que deux parfois de samples vous non
c'est extrêmement minimaliste
est-ce que c'est par économie où ces
volontaires c'est-à-dire qu'on vient pas
du rap traditionnel on a écouté mais à
la façon des deux formations de son
plutôt rock même s'il y avait d'autres
influences et l'allée des de s'assurer
de ses musiques pour créer quelque chose
d'un peu différent
ce qu on le fait aussi avec un autre
notre héritage rock donc enfin moi je
suis pianiste à la base donc on utilise
elle que ces outils-là en avec notre
expérience plus de gros en faisant
quelque chose d'un peu différent
donc on n'a pas cette tradition plus des
simples nicolas boet tout à fait on est
des rockers qui essayons de faire du rap
donc ce qu'on utilise les outils qu'on
connaît qui on a eu l'habitude de
l'utiliser depuis maintenant vingt ans
donc
donc voilà c'est de l' enregistrement
live c'est l'utilisation d'instruments
en direct on a très peu de programmation
sur ce disque par exemple donc très peu
de couches aussi très peu de bach
derrière au niveau des dévots des voix
donc effectivement vous avez raison
c'est ce est minimale parce que c'est
notre manière de d'entendre cette
musique et notre envie de la montrer
alors j'ai cherché d'autres clips de
vous qui sont sur internet il y en a qui
s'intitule le trottoir le morceau ne
figure pas sur le nouvel album mais on
va l'écouter quand même en tout cas un
extrait
[Musique]
chiant
gérard 2
[Musique]
cauchemar
alors c'est drôle parce que vos clips
ont l'air de se suivre de ce site et ou
de ceux de se répondre les uns les
autres vous faites pas de samples dans
votre musique
j'ai l'impression vous semblez vos clips
alors oui c'est vrai que là sur ce on a
fait une trilogie de clips en fait
qu'ils sont issus de notre première un
pays où il ya les deux morceaux là et
l'idée c'est de travailler vraiment cet
aspect trilogie autour de la figure du
monstre qui étaient des thématiques
fortes des textes de nicolas et on
travaille avec un réalisateur xavier
girardot pour mettre en images ce 1
autour de trois clips qui raconte une
histoire
donc c'est la même histoire que raconte
les trois clips
ça s'explique mieux pourquoi vous l'avez
vous avez appelé votre votre groupe 10
10 et parce que avec 120 c'est notre
dixième disque on peut ensemble et aussi
c'est aussi la figure bas du numéro 10
dans le football tout simplement parce
que ce numéro 10 dans le football il a
là on est des amoureux de foot moi
particulièrement j'adore le foot et tout
son imaginaire et le numéro 10 il porte
la responsabilité du jeu c'est lui qui
est le responsable technique c'est lui
qui est responsable de la victoire de la
défaite c'est sur lui qu'on va taper si
si on perd c'est luca badoer étiez si on
gagne donc ce numéro 10 ça ne plaisait
bien l'image
aujourd'hui on vous êtes un peu enfermé
chez vous comme comme tout le monde il
n'y a pas de scène qui se profile pas de
pas de live ça vous empêche pas de
travailler ou ça vous mine c'est assez
compliqué ne pas pouvoir défendre le
disque parce que parce que ça fait un
petit moment qu'on travaille dessus et
qu'on on a forcément envie de jouer dans
des gens après c'est comme ça c'est une
grande ville mondiale donc forcément on
fait avec comme tout le monde on n'est
pas les plus à plaindre on n'est pas
dans des dans des hôpitaux en train de
soigner des gens
donc y'a pas de souci là-dessus là par
contre on essaye de continuer à faire
des choses et puis on va essayer de
faire un livestream 18 décembre pour un
label américain fait qu'il faut
incorporer shon donc on va faire cela
extreme on va essayer de faire quelque
chose d'un peu jolie
on travaille aussi sur un ep avec des
artistes américains qu'on veut sortir en
début d'année prochaine donc ça nous
permet bassett eux aussi étant enfermés
comme nous ça nous permet de
comme on a du temps de pouvoir essayer
de faire des les invités sur des
morceaux aussi de créer des choses
ensemble
sandra dernier mot pardon juste
eurobonds tiers par rapport au fait de
confier des fois le le fait de changer
de contexte un peu de création c'est
intéressant aussi d'utiliser la
contrainte pour en faire autre chose et
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire un petit
pour l'instant peut pas faire de la m
on continue d'exister autrement merci
tous les deux c'est donc le groupe 10
qui sort un album intitulé et n'être
qu'au milieu des monstres pour l'instant
il est dit qu uniquement numérique mais
il fera bientôt en physique merci tous
les quatre d'avoir participé elle cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]